[Music]
katie's in san francisco hi katie how
are you
hi good to be here thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
um so i followed you pretty closely
after i graduated college and i ended up
paying off all of my student loans
thank you i have a credit card but no
credit card debt and i just feel like
now i've gotten this like quote big girl
job and i i've just had a hard time i
feel like i've hit a plateau after
paying off my debt of not being able to
i've saved up a thousand dollar
emergency fund but like i'll end up
spending it and i just feel like i've
hit a plateau where
i just can't save any money and i feel
like i'm spending all my money and i
just can't like get to the next step why
why hello why oh why um i'm not
budgeting
it's hard i guess i
um more money than you've ever had in
your life and you're broke i know i'm
very what are you spending your money on
katie where are the money leaks
happening
i mean you know in san francisco i'm
going out to eat
um experiences traveling could you go in
instead
could you have some friends over
yeah absolutely okay let's look let's
get creative and let's see what that
does for a month see how much money you
have left over and how it makes you feel
so katie you're trading short-term
thrills
for your future
yes and it's scary because i'm living
paycheck to paycheck and i don't want to
do that yeah and and you realize that
and so
now you have to decide each time you get
ready to go out to eat or go on a trip
you have to go i just gave away a piece
of my future
and i just brought stress into my life
so is the joy of the going out to the
club tonight
with the girls
uh is that joy
as is that equal to or greater than the
amount of anxiety i'm gonna feel when i
wake up with a financial hangover
tomorrow
no
that's why you're calling it
that's why you're calling and so but my
point is you've got to put that into a
day-by-day basis and quit doing some of
this stuff that you know you shouldn't
be doing
yeah i guess i i know i can do it
because i worked so hard to pay off over
like ten thousand dollars in debt and
then i just lost all
kind of i don't know i was like on a i
was born
you got you got a great income for the
first time you're making more money
you've ever made in your life and so
you're you know like you got lottery
itis like you hit the lottery or
something
right okay here's what i'll do to help
you build that muscle i'm gonna gift you
financial peace university and i'm gonna
want you to do two very specific things
watch lesson one which is on budgeting
and baby step one with rachel and watch
lesson five with dr john daloni and i on
wise spending i think those two things
combined will give you some tools in
your toolbelt to go all right i'm gonna
walk through the framework i'm gonna
walk through this process i'm gonna
commit to the plan and just do it for a
month and if you do that and you hate it
you can go back to the way you were
living but i think you're going to feel
that sense of relief and you go i'm in
control i'm confident in my money
decisions i can do this you got to ask
yourself how old are you
i'm 24. yes you got to ask yourself what
the 34 year old katie is she happy with
what you just did
totally she's going to be pissed
right you're so mad that's what you're
saying you're so lame you're not fun you
used to be fun
i don't want to keep living paycheck to
paycheck and i just i know that this
like method works because i feel like i
got with gazelle like intensity to that
stuff and now i'm just and i want to
continue going
and i'm going to be real harsh now are
you ready
yeah i'm ready you need some new friends
okay
all your friends do is what you're doing
you don't have anybody in your life
that's like a grown-up or you got party
girls in your life
you need some new friends
this is the ramsay show